now for something completely different
in truth not just different real knock
me down with a feather and pull me Nancy
unbloomed believable
I find myself supporting someone I've
seen in the past as a shrill pious
irritation no I'm not referring to
effort her demand at level Nelson's
column turn the area into a Botanical
Garden celebrating the flora and fauna
Africa nor Rachael's loopy Lib Dem
lunacy rather I find myself defending
the impossibly pompous Commons Speaker
John Burke oh now let me be candid I
think he needs to honor his promise and
go later this year as he vowed to do on
his election and an investigation into
claims of bullying which he denies is a
necessity however to be investigated for
using the word stupid to describe a
cabinet minister is absurd the comments
like many other workplaces a robust
place scarcely a day passes when the
thought police though tell us what we
are allowed to say or think it's nuts
and anyone supporting this snowflake
curry is not stupid I actually have this
is I find this a bit of a difficult one
okay the reason I find this difficult is
as you probably know I have a
zero-tolerance attitude towards bullying
in the workplace I think there should be
no place for it
I think we should be more willing than
we have in the past to cool it out and I
think that for a role like the speaker
where you are responsible for discipline
in the house it is especially important
that you have people's confidence that
you are someone who behaves fairly and
professionally yes denies any bullying
this is a debate on using the word
stupid it is a debate on using the word
stupid I suspect that the reason it's
being taken so seriously is because
these are the allegations of bullying
which haven't been proved which he
denies are also in the mix I also have a
little sympathy for him in the context
where he made that remark because it was
the government trying to abuse the rules
to use time that you use for grenfell
power you use make a government speech
which I can see why he was frustrated
and I can relate to that but I think I
don't think we should be some dismissive
of this kind of thing and I think you're
belittling the idea of stupid and it
does sound a little bit trivial in the
scheme of things but I think that it
wasn't for me
stupid it was stupid women yes it was
the fact that he mentioned her gender
and that there is a history of people
recognizing women's gender against them
really grateful I want to totally
imagine we just need to get in the
speaker's office have made a statement
or maybe said mr. speaker strenuously
denies that there is any substance to
any of these allegations mr. speaker has
a superb team of dedicated effective and
long serving staff five of whom have
worked for him very happily for a
combined total of over 40 years so
that's the statement from the speaker's
office it was important to get that
India that's regarding the the bullying
but on the word stupid I imagine he was
talking about a woman so I I don't know
if it's the fact that she was a woman
that he called her stupid for or perhaps
just because he felt she was stupid but
I think so I think I think if you call a
stupid man she may have taken offense
she's not a man I mean I know I think
the word stupid is a very relatively
mild let's just say he's and and you
know he's also responded to that to that
one stupid specifically as well they say
were they SSA I used the word stupid in
a muttered aside that adjective simply
summed up how I felt about the way that
that day's business had been conducted
anyone who knows the leader of the house
at all well will have not the slightest
doubt about her political ability and
her personal character I love this house
I respect all of my colleagues I hold
you all in the highest esteem I just
worry that if we're not even allowed to
use the word stupid in the context of a
little spat at the workplace anymore it
becomes so since aureus that we can't
express our true feelings in in a
conversation it's just tough you know
this became a story because of the
allegations which we have to make clear
that he has denied he has a reputation
for this news and I did a report last
year from his office also his old
private secretary Angus unclear who
resigned in 2010 was paid off not to
speak about this then did speak and said
he was a bully
another lady from his office was there
was
as to be moved because of so-called
Billy which he denies we have to be
clear on that you know this isn't just
any workplace this is the House of
Commons where where the rules on
politeness and respect or enforce
ruthlessly but no let me finish language
by the thing and it was interested that
the Bercow himself two years ago
introduced a sixteen page guide let me
tell you it was called the rules of
behavior and courtesies in the house
about this I think we saw from John
Bercow that he you know who does love
the sound of his own voice yes yes I
think that was a pitch to keep his job a
bit longer I mean my anxiety about this
topic is that I sort of feel that people
should be able to let off steam in the
workplace and otherwise what you know
what they say in public to your face and
what they say in private behind your
back there is such a chasm that I think
it's rather unfortunate I think that the
lady in question actually responded
rather well to what happened and she
didn't take it seriously and I she this
was John response as you said last week
Mr Speaker we have a responsibility to
safeguard the rights of this house and
as leader of the house I seek to do
exactly that treating all members of
parliament with courtesy and respect I
hope and expect all honorable and right
honourable members to do likewise
actually you know I've been extremely
rude and unpleasant about and really led
some in the past in print and I she's
made me feel well we were much better it
was much better to say it to her face
and take the consequence remind you of
another time that I feel gender was a
factor in condescending there here in
the house this is David Cameron founded
in 2011 who could forget it exactly but
he's now a GP says calm calm down dear
calm down
listen listen to the doctor
calm down and listen to the doctor it
makes just rewatching that it actually
almost as annoyed as you guys I can just
interrupt you for a moment ducky it's
quite a I'm kidding I'm kidding
let's just play this way we're a bit of
a clip fest but this for me
sums it up about where your brother
works where we just saw David Cameron
where we saw everybody else and a very
respected politician Ken Clark if every
time a member of this house has felt
moved to say under his breath something
rather abusive about another member
action was taken the chamber would be
deserted time it would you not agree
it's best to leave this to the body that
is now investigating it and perhaps hope
that some common sense will be applied
to this rather over heated subject
wouldn't ever would you not agree with
that they'll never be able to do a day's
work if we suddenly outlaw words such as
stupid I think it's difficult I agree we
need to be realistic about the reality
they work in on the other hand they are
supposed to set the tone there's
supposed to be two people elect Andrea
let's them currently in her job as
leaders a house is looking at questions
of whether Parliament's are sufficiently
well equipped to deal with bullying and
with Louise after the Westminster
scandals so it it would actually it just
seems to me the ultimate irony and maybe
maybe that's why he doesn't feel too
well disposed to her seeing that clip of
David Cameron there reminds me that the
speaker otherwise known as squeaker
Burke oh yeah has had to put up with a
lot of flack himself and David Cameron
once said you know he John Burke I said
I'm not happy and then David Cameron
said were which one of the Seven Dwarves
are you then remember that I mean he's
constantly being teased and belittled
literally belittled for being of
short-shorts Thatcher yes yes is whether
you can use the word stupid as what
we're discussing it is but there are be
you and I as colonies we wouldn't know
we'd never be able to call him out if we
could we had to be very scathing it
would take you all the color out of
language guys come
it's been driven to be at irritation
himself because he's constantly teased
about being said when he says stupid
woman will you know such people you
can't dispute that but she's not stupid
she's a woman as well isn't she she's
not stupid so what you perceived it if
for instance every time imagine went on
air at our radio station he kept saying
the wrong station or something like that
I'm perfect I said he's a stupid bloke
you know he really can't even name the
radius and he's not going to take
offence if I said BBC and you know and I
can't say but the other thing is
electric so it wasn't just something the
investigation is about stupid woman and
that's what it turns on if we can just
pick on which I think was actually one
of the brightest points and wrote when
Majid says it's Ref imagine take all the
color out of the language you will
effectively had said that is true is it
not that's what people said when you you
know when racial slurs thought they
acceptable in the workplace language was
normal which now we find completely
that's one every time it's killed you're
the same levels in comparing the word
I'm comparing the idea if you if you
have rules about what it isn't isn't
acceptable to say then you can't have
fun at work anymore I don't I just don't
buy them